the Joe Rogan experience the [ __ ]
mirror man like you with long-form
podcast you find out who the [ __ ]
everybody is yeah that's good that's a
good point
like like Bernie Sanders like I had
Bernie Sanders on yeah so a lot of
people that like the [ __ ] comments
were insanely positive to like I thought
that guy was crazy like I thought he was
a nut I would see him in these little
interviews and mic he just wants give
away everybody's money like there's a
picture with Bernie with my dog and one
of the [ __ ] hilarious comments like
he just wants to give your dog treats
other dogs that's the caricature I mean
everyone has a character right the
character that guy is he just wants to
take money from successful people and
give it to lazy people that's the worst
the worst view of Bernie Sanders you
know and you get to see instead of like
this narrative that gets established
through these little short sound bites
and these panel talk shows there's three
people talking over each other or
debates or whatever it is all those are
ineffective and what's interesting about
is all those are fueling podcasts all
those things that have so for so long
been thought of as mainstream venues for
getting your ideas out now they
highlight all the problems with those
and they highlight all the strengths of
podcasts that's encouraging yeah it's
very encouraging and remember are you
Bernie Sanders man he's a nice guy
you know I I I like some of his ideas I
do not have a problem with giving up
more of my money as a person who's made
a lot of money if I know that it's gonna
benefit the greater good of mankind you
know reason was he uh squandered I don't
want to see it squandered
I don't like bureaucracy I don't like
red tape I don't like government I don't
like people that are so lazy that they
just want to take everybody's money and
then do what they will with it and take
long lunch breaks and this is the
problem with like a lot of what we think
of in terms of like government
government is filled its bloated it's
filled with [ __ ] it's filled with
people that just got government jobs and
they're they're not good at it you know
they just no one else wants that job so
they take that job and they do a shitty
job with it and they squander resources
so it drives people crazy and especially
hard-working people that know how hard
it is to make a living you have to give
you know if you're a [ __ ] logger
you're given a certain percentage of
your money and you're tired all these
splinters in your hands and you're
exhausted and some [ __ ] is gonna take
away your money and you know and
allocate a certain amount of it to
nonsense no you know gender research and
all sorts of stupid [ __ ] that you think
is just fruitless and it's just it's
infuriating for people for hardworking
people it dirt under their fingernails
they don't want to think about anybody
squandering their money
no I'm instinctively yeah fiscally very
conservative you know not very fiscally
conservative people might look at where
I'm at and think that I'm socially
liberal but in social issues I'm
somewhat libertarian you know but I feel
that I need the right to come my
direction quite a long ways on
conservation issues but that's land
that's yeah that's instinctively where I
belong yeah but the the right but I need
them to move back my no when I say back
my direction because historically I
don't know the right unless hard to is
confusing but yeah I need them to come
my way on conservation well I'd like the
way you've described yourself in the
past that you're politically sort of
alone that you're you're you're kind of
without a party because the left ones
take your guns away and the right ones
take your lands away no and this is what
we see fiscally that what the most
disturbing aspects of right-wing
administration says they want to sell
off public land they want to figure out
a way just a little bit just a little
bit we're just taking a little bit we're
gonna use it for mining just take a
little bit well I meant lose the salmon
river but who the [ __ ] is painted edge
of that coming uh yeah I'm watching for
yes me too and that's Ryan Callahan
talked about that with what does it call
Pebble Beach that would no pebble and
Hubbell mine
yeah that mean gigantic salmon fishery
is the biggest most yeah it's a yeah
deeply on yeah I don't want to get it
too hard but yeah you can get into the
weeds with this stuff but yeah it's like
there's no perfect party and there's
no perfect politician there's no perfect
ideology which pisses people off when
you point that out do we've gotten hit
hard for that kind of stuff for pointing
out to this just not you know we as a
company like a mediator we've been like
hit hard for pointing out that it's
unfortunate that someone's not speaking
for our holy for our concerns yes well
it's interesting about you guys is
people think that your is some sort of a
green Trojan horse which is hilarious
you know like dude we don't really like
to hunt I love it
but it's so preposterous I work with the
hardest I work with the heart is hitting
I work with the hardest hit and hunter
and honors and fishermen that there that
there are ever that I've ever lived you
don't really like on its larious no
that's like some like Beltway lobbyists
you don't really like hunting oh is that
right it just shows you how silly people
are let's line them up yeah it's yeah
come on bring your side over here let me
see what you're doing yeah it's it shows
you how ridiculous people can be in
their their desire to like put people
into a very small easily dismissed
category mm-hmm you know it's like this
is what people love to do you know yeah
that's what you do that drives people
crazy as you defy your so hard to buck
it I love it I don't sit around night
thinking about you but I love it but I
think we need more people like